bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 1er avril
au 8e jour du conflit engagé par les
forces de l'otan contre le régime serbes
de slobodan milosevic les stratégies
respectives reste incertaine
la capture de trois soldats américains
parlent un serbe qui lance maintenant
pour vouloir les juges et provoque
beaucoup d'émotion aux états unis
explication philippe gassot depuis
washington à bruxelles au siège de
l'otan pas question de ralentir l'action
militaire nous serons en direct avec
laurent boussier à belgrade le président
milosevic mène une offensive médiatique
et tente de récupérer le chef albanais
modéré ibrahim rugova mais cette
actualité militaires et diplomatiques ne
peut faire oublier les dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés qui continuent
d'affluer vers l'albanie
nous retrouverons benoît duquesne et
bertrand cocq ouvert la macédoine où se
trouve ce soir jérôme baugnies en france
le gouvernement et sa majorité affronte
une crise interne les communistes
mouvement des citoyens et les verts
manifestent leurs divergences avec les
socialistes
et puis dans l'actualité le président de
la fédération française aussi keith mis
en examen dans le cadre de l' affaire de
dopage de l'équipe festina pendant le
dernier tour de france
la plus haute juridiction allemande qui
décide de rendre les enfants lancelin
timan à leur mère française qui rejette
donc le recours du père allemand qui les
avaient enlevés les indiens inuits du
grand nord canadien qui ont désormais
leurs étals unis navette est née
aujourd'hui au sein du canada trois
soldats américains membres de la force
de l'onu chargé de surveiller la
frontière de la macédoine ont été
capturés par les serbes stupéfaction aux
états unis et parmi les dirigeants de
l'otan engagés dans le conflit avec le
régime serbe
un peu comme si l'on avait oublié qu'une
guerre fait des morts des réfugiés mais
aussi des prisonniers les américains ont
découvert les images de leurs trois
soldats en se réveillant ce matin devant
leur télévision correspondance philippe
gassot ces images basse pratiquement en
boucle sur toutes les télévisions
américaines
les hommes ont été identifiés jayme
stone andrew ramirez et wenger laissent
les appartient le 4e régiment de
cavalerie stationnés en allemagne et
était utilisée en macédoine dans le
cadre d'une mission de maintien de la
paix
de l'otan c'est samedi burger conseiller
à la sécurité qui a prévenu le président
en l'état actuel des choses la mairie
qui exige un traitement décent et humain
les hématomes qu'on distingue sur le
visage notamment de james stones ont
choqué l'amérique demande l'application
de la convention de genève
aux termes de cette convention le
prisonnier n'est tenu que de donner son
nom son prénom son grade et son numéro
de matricule
comme vous le savez trois soldats sont
tombés hier des serbes
nous ferons tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour leur assurer un retour en
toute sécurité les considérez vous comme
des prisonniers de guerre
en l'état actuel des choses nous les
considérons comme détenues illégalement
bill clinton devrait prendre la parole
dans une demi-heure il ne manquera pas
de commenter la volonté de slobodan
milosevic de traduire les trois
prisonniers devant une cour militaire
alors philippe gassot cette capture de
soldats américains peut-elle modifier
l'opinion publique est et ce qu'elle
pense de l'action des états unis avec le
temps mais butait la mairie que s'est
toujours fait un point d'honneur de
ramener à la maison les boys qu'elle
envoie à la guerre et ce qu'il soit mort
ou vif alors on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure à norfolk william cohen a dit
que tout serait mis en oeuvre pour les
faire rentrer et depuis le milieu de la
nuit tournent sur toutes les télévisions
américaines en boucle pratiquement
l'image des trois hommes que vous venez
de voir donc
que va-t-il se passer dans l'opinion
publique vous avez les supporters de
bill clinton qui représente un petit 51
52% qui risque d'être confortée en
disant regardez monsieur milosevic n'a
toujours pas compris foule continue à
taper ou là vous avez les opposants à
ces frappes les 37 ou 38 % d'américains
qui pensent qu'ils n'ont rien à gagner
au kosovo et qui pourrait parfaitement
dire pour qui pourrait être humilié
c'est à dire regardez comment on traite
la mairie qu'on va donc rejoindre le
camp de clinton ou alors plutôt de dire
regardez on a tout à perdre sur le
kosovo laissons donc réponse à votre
question demain avec les tous premiers
sondages
merci philippe à bruxelles au siège de
l'otan s'est efforcé de rappeler que les
prisonniers doivent être traitées selon
les droits internationaux les
ça met qu'un parle d'une violation du
droit international violation de la
convention de genève sur les prisonniers
de guerre à belgrade la télévision à
diffuser vos diffusé des images des
trois hommes précisant qu'il serait
traduit dès demain devant une cour
martiale militaire au kosovo mais il
faut revenir sur les circonstances de
leur interception par les forces serbes
reportage à la frontière la macédoine et
du kosovo avec jérôme baugnies andré il
sera cet après midi dans le secteur où
les trois américains ont été kidnappés
hier une autre patrouille américaine
avec deux véhicules mesures élémentaires
de sécurité
nous sommes à quelques kilomètres de la
serbie la population de ces montagnes et
serbes hostile donc c'est sur ce chemin
que les américains sont tombés dans une
embuscade
la frontière était de kilomètres
explique ce berger elle n'est pas
matérialisé les hélicoptères de l'otan
ont poursuivi leurs recherches toute la
nuit en vain les trois hommes étaient
déjà à belgrade
c'est homme appartenait à une force de
l'onu chargés de garder la frontière
jusqu'à février dernier depuis ils sont
sous commandement américain
coopérons avec la force de réaction
rapide dans la base française de
kumanovo on sait depuis le début des
frappes de l'otan qu'il faut prendre un
maximum de précautions
nous évitons les provocations donc les
déplacements inutiles
nous évitons également les contacts de
trop proche de la frontière
vous savez que c'est les macédoniens qui
sont au contact de la frontière nous
avons simplement un petit dispositif de
renseignements entre nos positions et
les positions macédonienne pour
justement éviter d'être surpris
cet après-midi le porte-parole de
l'alliance a cru bon de rappeler que les
forces terrestres de l'otan notre aucun
caractère offensif et pour que leurs
soldats prisonniers soient détenus y
maintenant les américains ont décidé
d'entrer en contact avec belgrade via la
suède
à bruxelles le secrétaire général de
l'otan monsieur ravier cela n'a droit
non seulement mené avec les militaires
l'action des forces engagées dans la
bataille de bombes à
demain mais également conduire à une
offensive médiatique il lui faut donc
répondre à chaque fois au président
milosevic
ainsi aujourd'hui monsieur cela n'a
réaffirmé que l'otan n'arrêterait c'est
raide que lorsque les violences au
kosovo ce serait mais pour le général
américain commandant suprême des forces
alliées en europe
ces opérations aériennes sont
insuffisantes pour arrêter les exactions
explications laurent boursiers avec
maryse richard une semaine de frappes
une catastrophe humanitaire en marche et
trois soldats américains fait prisonnier
dans des circonstances encore troubles
en venant tout à l'heure devant la
presse le général wesley clark et javier
solana savait qu'ils étaient attendus et
que leurs explications devait couper
court aux rumeurs d'inefficacité des
actions militaires de l'otan premier
message à faire passer par le canal de
la presse musicale sera responsable de
la sécurité bien être des trois t3
sudaméricains sage est grave
deuxième message ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
présent a été efficace et on va
continuer carte à l'appui le commandant
suprême des forces de l'otan a fait le
bilan défense antiaérienne poste de
commandement dépôt de munitions de
carburant et troupes au sol tous ses
points représentent des objectifs
atteints dont la destruction doit
normalement réduire les capacités de
nuisance de l'armée serbe pourtant au
détour d'une phrase le général reconnaît
que les forces paramilitaires serbes
sont toujours à l'oeuvre kosovo et que
les raids de l'otan n'y peuvent pas
grand chose
les opérations aériennes seuls ne
peuvent pas arrêter les meurtres commis
par les forces paramilitaires
parfaitement reconnu une allusion
évidente à une éventuelle intervention
terrestre des troupes de l'otan
mais javier solana a immédiatement
relativisé la phrase du général clark
pour le secrétaire général de l'alliance
atlantique il ne pourra y avoir de
déploiement terrestre qu'à regret la
signature des accords de paix
manifestement laurent il ya débat entre
j'appellerai les politiques et puis les
militaires oui lorsqu'on peut dire ce
soir c'est que aujourd'hui le temps a
émis des signaux disons discordantes sur
l'envoi de troupes au kosovo d'un côté
il ya les militaires relayé souvent par
les organisations humanitaires qui
pensent que pour arrêter les exactions
au kosovo
il faut engager un combat aéro terrestre
et puis de l'autre côté il ya les
politiques pour qui 'la hantise c'est
l'engrenage et qu'ils connaissent en
plus la versatilité des opinions
publiques
pour eux il n'est pas question une
seconde donc d'engagement au sol
l'engagement terrestre au kosovo alors
les frappes vont donc continuer un jour
elles seront certainement raison des
défenses herbe mais ça n'est ni dans les
vingt-quatre ni dans les prochaines 48
heures en attendant ce mini cafouillage
à l'otan arrange monsieur milosevic ça
lui donne du grain à moudre
il peut en espérer face à lui un front
un peu moins unis merci tandis que
l'armée yougoslave et des de la police
ou de milices poursuit une manière de
vidage de plusieurs villes où que se
vaut les avions de l'otan ont multiplié
les bombardements frappant la nuit
dernière près du centre de la capitale
belgrade des cibles peut être militaire
mais pas seulement
comment quatre ans soit corner les
employés de l'usiné de cacak dans le
centre de la serbie sont revenus ce
matin à errer dans les ruines de leur
payer bombardé à deux reprises par les
avions de l'alliance la destruction de
cette cible qualifié de stratégique par
l'otan illustre toute la complexité de
cette guerre sur le plan de la
communication des pompes à eau dans mon
atelier 17 ouvriers et rien d'autre rien
d'autre c'est sûrement vrai
dans d'autres ateliers ont fabriqué
officiellement des produits
électroménagers mais aussi de l'armement
dit l'otan c'est pourquoi nous avons
détruit cette usine cette détonation à
5h ce matin est provoquée par un tir
missile qui a touché ce pont sur le
danube à novi sad au nord de belgrade
l'ouvragé a été entièrement détruit
construits après la seconde guerre
mondiale ce pont que l'on voit sur ces
images d'archivés relier la ville au
faubourg petro van ryn aujourd'hui c'est
un amas de ferraille et la population ne
comprend pas les habitants de novi sad
ont manifesté cet après midi contre ce
bombardement
l'objectif dans ce deuxième cas été sans
doute considérée également comme
stratégique par l'otan
la banlieue de belgrade a une nouvelle
fois été bombardée la nuit dernière et
les habitants inquiets sont retournés
aux abris sur place dans la capitale
yougoslave le témoignage de catherine
monnet monde sait que les frappes de
l'otan sont chirurgicale mais tout le
monde se dit aussi qu'il peut y avoir un
ratage était une zone vraiment
d'habitation qui plus est il ya une
angoisse par rapport à ce que peuvent
déclencher ces bombardements
centre-ville après sedan belgrade même à
beaucoup de personnes m'ont fait part de
leur inquiétude de voir se déclencher un
processus de violence à processus de
pillage de la ville en attendant l'otan
renforce son dispositif aérien avec ses
bombardiers stratégiques b1 mais aussi
en adriatique avec un sous-marin
nucléaire d'attaqué l'oeil ou à seysses
norfolk
dès hier soir nous vous l'annoncions le
chef modérée des albanais du kosovo
monsieur ibrahim rugova réapparaissait
la surprise n'est pas mince on l'avait
dit blessés réfugiés quelque part en
europe hors du territoire yougoslave
mais monsieur rue gauvin était à
pristine à protéger entre guillemets par
les forces serbes à ce point protégé qu
on le découvrait ce matin en compagnie
du président milosevic à belgrade
commentaires jean noir qu'il ose que
vaut cette étrange poignée de main entre
à gauche ibrahim rugova chef des
nationalistes kosovars modéré et
slobodan milosevic numéro un serbe et
grand ordonnateur du nettoyage ethnique
au kosovo la rencontre montrées par la
télévision serbe a eu lieu ce matin même
au palais présidentiel à belgrade
elle a même donné lieu à la signature de
ce communiqué ou les deux hommes est il
écrit se disent d'accord pour préférer
un règlement politique des problèmes
question ibrahim rugova dont on était
sans nouvelles sûres jusqu'à hier soir
est il encore aujourd'hui un homme libre
hier soir la télévision serbe l'avait
entre guillemets retrouver à pristina
capitale du kosovo nation que je suis
est que
je suis apte été aussi blessés et aussi
que l'huile à ibrahim rugova
interrogèrent si hier soir en anglais
parlait déjà de solution diplomatique
mais contrairement aux premières
informations il n'a jamais réclamé
l'arrêt des bombardements de l'otan
alors même que la question lui a été
posée ici à plusieurs reprises
longtemps partisan de la simple
résistance passive au pouvoir serbe
ibrahim rugova malgré son prestige
incontestable avait été largement
éclipsé pendant les négociations de
rambouillet par hashim thaçi le jeune
chef de guerre de l'armée de libération
du kosovo le 20 mars il avait repris la
route du kosovo ce soir ses partisans
demeurait en europe souligne que la
télévision serbe n'a pas montré sa
famille et estime que monsieur roux bova
pourrait être l'objet d'un chantage et
monsieur milosevic ne s'est pas contenté
de cet effet médiatique puisqu'il a
ostensiblement reçu un envoyé spécial du
pape jean paul ii monseigneur torrent ce
français est considéré comme le ministre
des affaires étrangères du vatican le
pape souhaite une trêve pascale
mais aussi bien les etats-unis que
l'otan décliné cette invitation un
cessez le feu même provisoire à moscou
le président boris helsinki a décidé
l'envoi de bâtiments militaires de la
flotte russe en adriatique seulement
pour se renseigner dit il réclame
également une réunion d'urgence des
ministres des affaires étrangères
représentant les huit grands pays
industriels soient les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne la france l'allemagne
l'italie le canada le japon + 20 russe
les militaires russes membres de la
force de stabilisation de l'otan vaste
formes présentes en territoire de bosnie
mais plus précisément dans la zone dite
de la république serbe autonome reste
sous commandement américain ce qui n'est
pas sans poser quelques difficultés
compte tenu du conflit engagé
de l'autre côté de la frontière
bosniaques une équipe de france 2 avec
maryse burgot hérite de l'agneau a suivi
quelques militaires russes aujourd'hui
il s'appellerait guilly inya tôt
sur la base militaire du levitch 7 costa
blement lui le patron
nous sommes dans un camp russe de la
sfor la force de stabilisation de l'otan
beauce où le colonel ignatov comme tous
les matins s'apprête à rentrer en
conférence il rend des comptes à son
commandement américain tard ici russes
et américains travaillent ensemble pour
maintenir la paix en bosnie ce qui
n'empêche nullement le colonel qui a son
franc parler de dire ce qu'il pense des
bombardements de l'otan
moi je devrais arrêter ces bombardements
aériens
lorsqu'ils attaquent les serbes ils ne
font que renforcer leur détermination
c'est n'importe quoi le contingent russe
de la sfor a logiquement été installés
dans la partie serbe de la bosnie la
population locale accepte bon gré malgré
cette présence militaire les
traditionnels bonnes relations entre
moscou et milosevic font passer la
pilule les serbes de bosnie ne jure
aujourd'hui que par le président russe
celui qui a tant fait pour à rester
l'otan nous nous sentons bien plus à
l'aise avec les russes les américains 11
et bombardé le centre historique
cette guerre c'est à nos frères qui la
font
retour à la base du glitch ici pas un
haut gradé pas d'un sergent n'a trouve
l'intervention de l'otan c'est
l'unanimité sur b d'abord je voudrais
dire que les serbes sont laissés à nîmes
moi je ne comprends votre comme le dieu
chrétien costard inquiet des hommes par
de la même rue pas de machines luc
servant pour les militaires russes
les serbes ont construit dans le camp
une église orthodoxe
les relations sont décidément au beau
fixe malgré les tensions entre moscou et
les occidentaux sur la crise du kosovo
ici en bosnie la coopération continue
entre russes et américains et il n'est
pas question pour l'instant de
bouleverser le fragile équilibre que les
hommes de la sfor maintiennent ici ce
que l'on appelle la catastrophe
humanitaire au kosovo c'est à dire le
flot de réfugiés venus du kosovo
s'amplifie
la voici sur cet écran en chiffres sec
pour le monténégro 27000 pour la
macédoine 29,8 pour l'albanie cent mille
ce sont les chiffres provisoires bien
sûr du nombre de réfugiés puis il
faudrait parler de ceux qui sont partis
en bosnie en turquie en bulgarie
cette catastrophe humanitaire ce sont
des visages des femmes des hommes des
enfants forcés par les serbes d'utiliser
tous les moyens pour quitter leur pays
comme ceux de pristina les images vous
allez voir sont rassurantes elles nous
ont été fournies sous contrôle serbe et
volt accréditer un déplacement de
populations paisibles
mais ces réfugiés de christina sont
arrivés en albanie franchissant sous le
contrôle des policiers albanais une
frontière qui ne signifie pas pour
autant la fin de leur misère reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux
benoît duquesne et didier deshamps ma
tante une file ininterrompue de
tracteurs et de voitures
seize mille surpasser cette nuit autant
sans doute plus attendre que les serbes
alors à quoi bon les chiffres car les
autorités albanaises ont changé de
technique de question de rentrer sans
contrôle d'absorber comme elles viennent
les vagues de réfugiés
cette fois on enregistre chaque nom
chaque numéro de châssis réfugiés par
réfugiés et ça prend des heures en
faisant comme ça ça va prendre des
semaines
adam ni tu sais je n'ai pas besoin de
dire quels risques qu'encourent les gens
qui sont de l'autre côté c'est pas
exactement de quelle longueur et là que
rend tournée dans la région emma bonino
ne pouvait rêver mieux pour se rendre
compte de la situation
elle vient évaluer l'urgence des besoins
l'évaluation est toute faite
le gouvernement albanais déborder le
faire donc je pense que jamais
enfin on va pouvoir tenir je lui jetait
le monde des scènes tout comme ça tout
comme ça depuis 91 que le moment est
venu narguer zinal
assez c'est assez pourtant après la
région de prizren c'est pristina la
capitale du kosovo que les serbes ont
entrepris de vider et peu importe qu'il
y ait des morts en route sa big ben à la
vanille arrive de christina avec sa
femme et ses trois enfants
il a préféré finir la route à pied la
tente était trop longue en territoire
serbe et la peur insurmontable parce
qu'il prend les tiac a précisé la police
est entrée dans nos maisons
ils nous ont dit qu'on avait cinq
minutes et nous en aller ce qui ne va
pas on sait bien il leur arrive alors de
peur on est parti avec les enfants on a
souffert le martyre sous la route n'y a
pas de mot pour décrire cela le martyr
ce sont les policiers les miliciens
serbes omniprésent c'est la route de la
macédoine interdite les villages
traversés et brûler les magasins pillés
les humiliations les insultes et la peur
à chaque instant de se faire tuer sa
[ __ ] balaban il laisse derrière lui son
agence de marketing et sa belle maison
dans un quartier résidentiel de
christina il n'est pas sûr d'avoir
laissé sa peur se donnant à prestine un
jour et nuit on entend les bombardements
les rafales dans les rues les maisons se
tataner toutes les boutiques des
albanais sont pillées et brûlées il n'y
a que le secteur public la fonctionne il
ne sert que les serbes ont réagi aux
bombardements de la manière la barbare
surtout après celui contre le quartier
général de la police où faute de pouvoir
répliquer que se sont acharnés sur nous
sur notre club et dont une femme que sa
liberté après sept jours terrait dans sa
maison sans sortir sa [ __ ] balle à banny
a pu sauver ses enfants échapper au
serbe qui regroupe et les hommes dans le
stade de la ville
il n'a pas pu sauver ses parents les
serbes ne lui en ont pas laissé le temps
jusqu'à présent la région de coutances a
pu absorber la moitié des cent mille
réfugiés qui sont arrivés ici loi thiais
a été dirigé vers le sud du pays mais
chacun sait bien que les capacités
d'hébergement arriveront vite à
saturation
il faut donc ouvrir des camps et vite ne
serait ce que pour recenser répertorier
tous ces réfugiés
c'est la proposition d' emma bonino les
forces serbes auraient fait embarquer
5000 kosovar dans un train destination
la macédoine puis sous la contrainte
les en force et effectué les derniers
kilomètres à pied alors gérant boni ce
soir à la frontière de la macédoine
quelle est la situation des réfugiés qui
continuent d'arriver
oui effectivement l'hémorragie du kosovo
vers la macédoine se continue également
comme vous le disiez il y en a qui sont
arrivés par la voie ferrée et met à pied
le train ayant été arrêté en fait par
les autorités macédoniennes d'après mes
informations puis donna qui arrive en
tracteur par les montagnes il y en a qui
arrivent par la route de l'autre côté de
ce poste frontière des général jancovic
il y aura encore douze mille personnes
qui attendent dans des voitures ou à
pied qui vont passer la nuit dans le
froid ici il y a maintenant à peu près
trente mille réfugiés c'est à dire que
le nombre de réfugiés en macédoine a
doublé depuis le début des frappes
aériennes et le gouvernement macédonien
lance un appel au secours vous savez qui
s'il ya un problème d' équilibre
démographique entre les macédoniens et
les albanais ce gouvernant donc lancé un
appel au secours à l'europe
il ne suffit pas de nous donner de
l'argent pour accueillir les réfugiés
qui souvent sont accueillis dans des
familles mais il faut aussi organiser
maintenant des sites d quand il y en a
un certain nombre près de cette
frontière
il faut aussi nous aider à ce que ce
déséquilibre démographique ne
déstabilise pas
la macédoine est donc le gouvernement
macédonien demande aux pays de l'europe
d'accueillir eux-mêmes certains dossiers
réfugiés merci jérôme et c'est la
capitale albanaise tirana qui reçoit
actuellement l'essentiel de l'aide
humanitaire internationale
des avions français ont atterri à tirana
chargé de 40 tonnes de fret
aujourd'hui reportage bertrand cocq
roger motte
la france a été la première cet après
midi a posé ses gros porteurs sur
l'aéroport de tirana 4 transall un
hercules c 130 40 tonnes d'aidé
humanitaire en faire un tas plutôt une
palette ipad est de là-bas jusqu'au mans
n'ont pas quoi faire un tabac et je vous
avais amené forcément les tons que de
l'huile végétale des couvertures
principalement ses premières palettes
sont immédiatement prise en charge par
le hcr l'organisation des nations unies
pour les réfugiés
leur contenu servira à équiper des camps
en prévision d'un nouvel afflux bonne
partie des gens actuellement
actuellement son sont par famille
d'accueil mais les capacités d'accueil
sont vont être saturés sont déjà
saturées et donc on anticipe un petit
peu par la construction malheureusement
on est obligés la construction de camps
en tant que de façon très rapide avec de
la nourriture à transformation sans
cuisson et avec des couvertures pour
pallier au plus pressé dans une première
étape
l'arrivée de ses premiers colis coïncide
avec la visite à tirana du ministre
français délégué à la coopération entre
deux entretiens officiels monsieur
jocelyn visite les réfugiés le gymnase
transformé en centre d'accueil
il en sort avec quelques idées
moi je pensais des écrans de télévision
avec des cartoons avait avec des jeux
des dessins animés des choses comme ça
je pense 60 ans c'est le début d'un
assaut aérien auquel tout ça qui va
permettre à la générosité de la france
mais des français de s'exprimer en
direction des populations de leur opus
pâte à mesurer l'extrême souffrance
en attendant les kosovars continuent
d'arriver dans la capitale albanaise par
petits groupes
serrant leur baluchon autour du chef de
famille ils vont parler rue et la ville
les absorbent les intègre à sa pagaille
comme des parents pauvres des cousins de
province provisoirement tomber dans le
malheur bertrand cocq qu'on dit début
d'un pont aérien donc c'est pour
l'instant notoirement insuffisant tout
ce qui arrive
oui bien entendu claude vous vous en
doutez il faudrait beaucoup plus il
faudra beaucoup plus et le temps presse
car on annonce ici en albanie l'arrivée
de nouveaux réfugiés kosovars il en
viendrait de macédoine il en viendrait
de bulgarie le nord du pays est déjà
complètement saturé vous l'avez vu tout
à l'heure dans le reportage de benoît
duquesne
alors bien sûr la solidarité des
albanais ne se dément pas mais vous
savez dans quelle situation se trouve ce
pays et ses deux millions et demi
d'habitants
près de 60 % d'entre eux sont au chômage
l'état est presque inexistant la mafia
fait la loi
bref tout cela inspire le plus vives
inquiétudes
alors si l'on veut aider les albanais à
assumer ce fardeau
il faut bien sûr une aide humanitaire
une aide d'urgence mais il faut aussi
une volonté politique la mise en place
d'un véritable plan de coopération au
niveau de l'europe entière il en va
certainement de la stabilité de la
région toute entière
merci bertrand plusieurs organisations
non gouvernementales françaises
international organise déjà des
opérations de secours des appels aux
dons sont lancés en mettant votre
disposition sur le site internet de
france 2 ou par télétexte s'inscrit en
bas de cet écran les adresses de toutes
ces organisations humanitaires
actuellement mobilisés exemple avec le
reportage d' ilana moryoussef et
jean-paul chaussée
toute la journée les équipes de médecins
sans frontières ont chargé 20 tonnes de
matériel humanitaire
vingt mille couvertures des kits
médicaux des tentes partie par camion en
fin d'après midi
un matériel d'urgence une aide qui
répondent aux besoins spécifiques des
réfugiés kosovars du mali aux abris dans
une première dans une première phase est
liée également à la distribution d'eau
et aux produits médicaux aux médicaments
de base ce matin le premier avion
humanitaire a décollé de beauvais à son
bord 15 tonnes de matériel d'une valeur
d'un million et demi de francs là encore
une préoccupation répondre à l'urgence
essentiellement faire des consultations
un peu de bobologie et puis toutes les
maladies qui vont arriver avec
l'hygiène pas très bonne à la lcf les
informations collectées par les équipes
sur le terrain permettent d'évaluer les
besoins
li mètres cubes de matériel vont partir
dans les tout prochains jours
de la nourriture mais surtout des
stations d'épuration d'eau que la
priorité des priorités à l'heure
actuelle c'est quand même de trouver un
accueil un abri un toit est d'apporter
de l'eau dans ce lieu où il va y avoir
une grande concentration de personnes
donc des risques d'épidémies d une ride
des risques liés à l'hygiène les
associations surprise par le nombre des
réfugiés auront besoin d'argent comme le
secours populaire qui a lancé une
campagne lundi elle s'apprête à faire
appel à la générosité des français
à bonn ce soir les représentants de
l'union européenne des nations unies et
des pays voisins de la yougoslavie se
sont réunis pour une conférence
internationale sur les réfugiés du
kosovo christian mary mono est la bonne
est ce qu'il y a des résultats déjà
concret de cette première conférence
première initiative l'annoncent d'un
conseil européen extraordinaire consacré
à la situation au kosovo une réponse en
sommes à la préoccupation française qui
avait exprimé hier par le président
jacques chirac en réunissant donc
aujourd'hui à bonn les huit pays
limitrophes à cette région comme
l'albanie la macédoine contournant tenu
certains témoignages l'allemagne a voulu
connaître un peu leurs préoccupations le
rend pas deux priorités
tout d'abord intervenir rapidement pour
soulager les souffrances des réfugiés
qui sont que vous savez des centaines de
milliers sur les routes
l'europe a les moyens financiers elle a
lancé plusieurs centaines de millions de
francs qui sont débloqués pour
intervenir là également l'infrastructure
pour intervenir et c'est le faire elle
peut nourrir plus de cent mille
personnes pendant plus d'un mois
deuxième priorité la stabilité dans la
région
hélas il était difficile de donner une
réponse concrète l'allemagne avait bien
sûr une préoccupation en organisant
cette réunion internationale rappeler
qu'en 1991 elle avec l'ip le 350 mille
réfugiés au cours de la guerre de bosnie
plus que tous les autres pays européens
réunis
elle souhaite cette fois que l'europe
fasse un effort conséquent
enfin les pays tout autour de la table
on souhaite
t'es lancé un appel à la russie pour
qu'elle intervienne une nouvelle fois
auprès de belgrade pour tenter
d'intervenir et mettra fin aussi
rapidement que possible à cette grave
crise en europe
merci christian mary et puis washington
a fait savoir on réponse donc à monsieur
helsinki n'était pas très favorable et
réunion d'un sommet des huit pays les
plus riches du monde
la mobilisation de ceux qui contestent
l'action de l'otan en yougoslavie reste
forte
plusieurs défilés plus ou moins fournis
ont eu lieu en france aujourd'hui je
cite par exemple lyon montpellier nancy
orléans ou encore strasbourg
d'autres manifestations toute cette
pression rassemblé des milliers de
personnes à genève berlin lisbonne est
encore à washington devant la maison
blanche mais c'est à paris en fin
d'après midi à l'appel notamment du
parti communiste que se tenait le
rassemblement le plus important pour la
france commentaire laurent hakim olivier
journée la manifestation pro serbe
improvisé place de la république avant
le départ du cortège n'était pas
forcément du goût des organisateurs qui
entendait donner un autre ton au défilé
clinton chirac-jospin assassin n'était
bien sûr pas prévu dans les slogans
officiels de ce nouveau rassemblement
contre les frappes de l'otan en
yougoslavie
et puis la vraie manifestation a
finalement débuté derrière quelques
figures politiques qui revendiquait un
rassemblement unitaire
c'est une manifestation unitaire de tous
ceux qui s'opposent à la guerre qui
s'oppose aussi à la dictature de
milosevic en serbie qui exigent le droit
à l'autodétermination du peuple du
kosovo mais qui pense que la guerre
menée par l'otan
les américains aidés en cela par le
gouvernement est la pire des choses
ouane ministre dans le cortège un
mouvement des citoyens particulièrement
discret le mdc de jean pierre
chevènement s'était pourtant associé à
l'appel des nombreux organisateurs
les communistes refusait de parler d'
avertissement lancé au gouvernement il
ya pas assez de progrès belligérants
par linda hardy cependant il s'agit là
d' exprimer
le pignon je répète partagé par des
visions et milan 3 1 des français
les pro serbe indésirables ont bien
tenté de conduire le défilé avant d'être
rapidement mise à l'écart la
manifestation prévue pour condamner la
guerre ne pouvait donner l'illusion de
soutenir bellegrave les conséquences de
la crise au kosovo sont rudes pour la
vie politique française à droite ce
matin monsieur charles pasqua dans les 4
vérités sur france 2 contestait le choix
de la france l'engagement de france aux
côtés de l'otan rude aussi pour la
coalition gouvernementale monsieur
jospin a dû rappeler fermement la
nécessité de cohésion même s'il laisse
une certaine liberté de parole à ses
ministres communistes à madame voynet à
monsieur chevènement qui exprime dans
inquiétude devant l'engagement de la
france derrière les etats unis
reportage avis inverse jacques gregor il
était le plus attendu des ministres
mais aujourd'hui jean claude gayssot est
resté silencieux
après les états d'âme exprimés hier par
les communistes retour donc à une
certaine discipline dans les rangs de la
majorité plurielle c'est en tout cas
l'effet recherché à matignon premier
visiteur ce matin laurent fabius premier
rappel alors qu'il pouvait être
totalement celui de ce qui se crée
d'abord parce qu'il y a des
français qui sont engagés des soldats
qui se sont engagés et puis parce que
quand on a une situation aussi lourde
aussi difficile il faut faire bloc
c'est clair la cohésion du gouvernement
ne seraient pas atteints qui s'exprime
est-ce que c'est pas normal nous avons
fonctionné comme ça de culte est en fête
lionel jospin a dû s'accommoder des
divergences d un des interrogations des
autres il a constaté que cela s'est
passé hier sous les yeux de jacques
chirac
mais il n'a pas du tout apprécié en
revanche le profit qu'a voulu en tirer
la droite
alors aujourd'hui on a été priée de
s'expliquer entre eux soit même si
officiellement il n'y a pas eu de rappel
à l'ordre
on sent tellement solidaires du
gouvernement
le question de faire état de ses
conquêtes que l'inspection d'apparence
physique d'un gouvernement qui est loin
d'être avéré concluant de ce premier
coup de chauffe dans le gouvernement que
chacun semble dire lionel jospin
retourne à son secteur d'activité
jour des sujets importants
les perspectives budgétaires parce qu'il
ya aussi le pays
à mentionner l'on va
deux passions
la solidarité gouvernementale a tout de
même souffert un enlisement du conflit
pourrait encore les prouver voilà alors
malgré toutes ces déclarations d'un
patient dans une sorte de logique de
crise gouvernementale en tout cas lionel
jospin doit gérer au plus près les
risques d'une crise gouvernementale org
bien sûr depuis qu'elle est au pouvoir
la gauche plurielle a dû faire face à
plusieurs fois ses contradictions sur le
traité d'amsterdam son mouvement des
chômeurs sur les sans papiers mais rien
qui n'ait tu la gravité et la charge
symbolique que d'un désaccord sur une
opération de guerre à droite d'ailleurs
ne sied pas trompé en appuyant là où ça
fait mal les critiques par le pc de
l'intervention yougoslavie affaiblirait
le gouvernement français attitude
inacceptable qui impliquerait la
démission des ministres communistes
monsieur jospin une certaine manière a
défini des règles du jeu non oui le
débat qui existe dans l'opinion selon le
premier ministre doit pouvoir s'exprimer
au sein du gouvernement mais de façon
mesurée des inquiétudes des
interrogations plutôt que des critiques
et en tout cas pas sur la place publique
un compromis auquel d'hergé en
s'exprimant hier sur le perron de
l'elysée la ministre du tourisme mme
michelle demessine
d'où un nouveau rappel à l'ordre ce
matin lors du séminaire gouvernemental
message apparemment reçu les ministres
communistes on l'a vu sont restés
silencieux et ils n'ont pas participé ce
soir à la manifestation
alors pour le reste les socialistes
renvoie le parti communiste à sa
schizophrénie entre pacifisme réflexes
anti haute année puis volonté de rester
au gouvernement
un équilibre délicat compte tenu de la
poursuite des opérations militaires
alors que l'opinion s'interroge de plus
en plus sur les faits limitée des
bombardements et sur la tragédie subie
par les populations du kosovo et puis un
équilibre qui deviendrait intenable en
cas d'intervention des forces terrestres
merci gérard alors avant de refermer
provisoirement ce chapitre du conflit
engagé par l'otan au kosovo
je vous convie à suivre ce soir sur
france 2 après cette édition envoyé
spécial bernard benyamin vous avez en
effet modifié le sommaire de votre
magazine
en effet claude nous allons consacrer
une bonne partie du magazine à la
situation au kosovo avec en particulier
un reportage qui nous permettra pour la
première fois de pénétrer dans le bon
coeur du commandement général situé en
plein paris où nous pourrons suivre avec
l'état major les opérations qui se
déroulent en yougoslavie sur les
ordinateurs les cartes magnétiques nous
irons aussi sur le porte avions foch qui
croise en adriatique sur la base
italienne discret n'a
sont basés les mirages franche et enfin
en macédoine avec les troupes qui devait
assurer le maintien de la paix au kosovo
si les accords de rambouillet avait été
signé nous reviendrons également sur les
racines de la guerre au kosovo avec un
reportage tourné à pristina la capitale
avant le déclenchement des bombardements
qui nous montrent en particulier la
haine qui prévalait entre serbes et
kosovars et qui nous aide à comprendre
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans cette
région du monde
voilà pour le kosovo mais nous avons
aussi deux autres reportages l'un sur
les détectives de l'adn et ses
implications de notre vie quotidienne un
reportage fascinante et les lois et
l'autre sur un monde que vous connaissez
bien je crois claude le monde de la
télévision
les grandes manoeuvres des industriels
pour lui a volé à bon merci beaucoup à
la rochelle cet après midi une foule de
milliers de personnes ont rendu hommage
à monsieur michel crépeau le député
maire de la ville décédé mardi monsieur
lionel jospin de nombreux membres du
gouvernement c'est qu'une centaine de
députés de toutes tendances étaient
présents reportage albert nicosie marcel
martin devant la mairie dans les rues
piétonnes du centre-ville partout la
même foule impressionnante et recueillie
michel crépeau a reçu cet après midi un
double hommage celui de la nation au
plus haut niveau
le premier ministre un tiers du
gouvernement
une centaine de députés issus des
différentes familles de la gauche ont
voulu saluer celui qui fut avant tout un
ami fidèle
pour moi la nous c'était l'autre
attentive le camarade joyeux des tables
partager le compagnon 10 malicieux monde
ide dans les rues de votre ville
et puis tout au long du cortège vers la
cathédrale l'émotion des anonymes
habitants de la rochelle dont il fut
beaucoup plus que le maire pendant 28
ans
un résultat très franc
les convictions qui concernerait puis je
crois que c'est quelqu'un de peine
beaucoup bénin j'ai envie de dire
aujourd'hui étudiant vent perdu leur
meilleur allié ce soir la ville a revêtu
ses habits de deuil
l'émotion est tangible elle témoigne de
l'attachement d'une villa son premier
magistrat dont l apprécier aussi le sens
de l'humour et l'humanisme à lille juge
d'instruction chargé de l'affairé de
dopage révélé lors du dernier tour de
france a mis en examen le président de
la fédération française de cyclisme sur
balles mais le directeur de la société
du tour a évité cette mise en examen
l'un était donc furieux l'autre soulagé
reportage
anne mourgues et dominique maes est
sortie du palais de justice soulager ses
explications semble-t-il convaincu le
juge
non il n'a rien à voir à lille affaires
de dopage le patron du tour de france
n'est donc pas mises en examen à l'issue
de mon audition par les services du srpj
de lille le procès verbal de mes
réponses été transmis au juge qu'elle le
juge qu'elle s'est déclaré satisfait des
réponses que je vais lui avait que je
lui avais apporté en conséquence je ne
suis pas mis en examen est maintenant au
travail farid ou baisser dans un peu
plus d'une semaine
merci monsieur jean marie leblanc
regarde vers l'avenir
daniel balle lui n'a pas eu droit au
même traitement
il est vrai que ce matin convoqué par
les policiers de lille
le président de la fédération française
de cyclisme refuse de répondre à leurs
questions une heure plus tard ils se
retrouvent dans le bureau du juge se
voit notifier sa mise en examen
il se dit révolté les accusations que te
porter contre les instances est contre
moi ne change absolument pas fondées car
quand c'est du ragot quand c'est du
mensonge
là il faut savoir se défendre et je suis
content au moins d'avoir pu me défendre
et d'expliquer très clairement que bien
évidemment certains ont intérêt
aujourd'hui à ce que les accusations
soient portées sur d'autres car pour eux
c'est important pour peut-être réduire
leur peine et leur responsabilité
daniel balle inquiéter une nouvelle mise
en examen dans le monde du cyclisme
après une longue série lundi dernier
vice-président de la fédération roger
loger avait subi le même sort
le lendemain c'était au tour de richard
virenque l' affaire avait débuté en
juillet dernier avec le soigneur d'une
équipe après neuf mois d'enquêté
c'est maintenant le cyclisme français à
sa tête qui est touché
et puis en belgique aujourd'hui lors de
la conception des trois jours de la
panne les gendarmes ont neutralisé
l'épreuve pour interpeller les coureurs
les dirigeants de l'équipe mapei oise
avoir saisi des produits présumés de pan
finalement seul un soigneur de cette
équipe et tignes en cause par le
procureur de courtrai la cour
constitutionnelle allemande de karlsruhe
c'est à dire la plus haute instance
juridique de la république fédérale
allemande vient de trancher dans le
différend qui opposait un père et une
mère divorcée pour la garde de leurs
enfants
le père allemand monsieur armin timan a
vu son recours rejeté
et c'est donc la mer une française
madame cosette lancelin qui obtient que
ses enfants reviennent avec elle en
france sa décision est très importante
pour tous les couples binationaux
séparés et en situation conflictuelle
l'explication patrick fandio cause est
l'hes ans l'inde dont la chambre vide de
ses deux enfants
c'était il ya quatre mois une période de
doute et de désarroi
la justice allemande venait de lui
refuser la garde de caroline et mathias
mes enfants je sais et je sais qu'ils
sont dans une situation difficile
actuellement donc oui j'ai l'espoir
attraits de l'espoir mais aussi de la
persévérance il lui en a fallu presque
un an jour pour jour après l'enlèvement
de ses enfants par son ex mari
la décision de la cour suprême allemande
met fin à l'incroyable bras de fer
judiciaire entre la france et
l'allemagne une bataille de procédure à
rebondissements
pas moins de huit décisions de justice
quatre favorables à la mer autant pour
le père la faire et est remontée
jusqu'au sommet de l'état
il y a dix jours encore elisabeth guigou
était à bonn pour évoquer le cas lance
l'un avec son homologue allemande pour
les associations qui défendent les
parents d'enfants enlevés issus de
couples binationaux
c'est une première victoire qui en
appelle d'autres
c'est un problème de fond qu'il faut
régler c'est pas des problèmes au cou au
cas par cas
évidemment il ya tellement de gens qui
sont dans cette situation il faut aller
plus loin maintenant il faut traiter le
le problème à la base
hermine qui émane n'a plus ce soir la
garde de ses deux enfants cosette
lancelin est venu les chercher dès
l'annoncé du jugement
elle est actuellement en route vers la
france vers une nouvelle vie qui
reprendra dès demain matin ses enfants à
ses côtés c'est aujourd'hui le premier
jour d'un nouvel état le nunavut c'est
celui des indiens inuits du canada qui
voit enfin reconnaître leur territoire
de la nouvelle article presque aussi
grand que celui de l'europe de l'ouest
ce nouvel état fait maintenant partie de
la fédération canadienne il lui reste
c'est pas mal à trouver les moyens de
son développement autonome reportage
dominique derda edouard perrin à
l'époque personne n'avait rien osé dire
rares étaient les inuits qui comprenait
la langue des blancs plus rare encore
été les blancs qui parlait celle des
inuits à la fin des années 50 pour
sédentariser ces indigènes qui
parcourait le grand nord la gendarmerie
royale du canada avait reçu ordre
d'abattre tous les chiens
je m'en souviens très bien c'était il ya
longtemps de votre petit comme ça ça
s'est passé là-bas derrière près de la
mer ils ont pris leurs fusils ils ont
tué la firme au bac c'était pas bien 13
ans
les missionnaires déjà les avaient
précédés ils sont toujours là
venu sauver les âmes de ses adeptes du
chamanisme qui vénérait la nature et
parlait aux esprits ils auront enseigner
les dix commandements et la crainte de
la colère divine
chaque dimanche l'église paix sale con
non loin de là pourtant c'est un tout
autre temple que l'on est déjà là à
celui où bientôt siègeront les députés
et le gouvernement du nunavut les 25000
habitants de ce nouveau territoire aussi
vaste que l'europe occidentale vont
enfin pouvoir eux mêmes prendre les
décisions qui les concernent
les choses ne vont pas changer du jour
au lendemain mais au moins les gens
auront le sentiment d'avoir leur mot à
dire
notre gouvernement ne nagera pas mais
nous aurons le contrôle de l'éducation
logement des services sociaux des choses
qui nous concerne est quotidiennement
il aura fallu vingt ans de patientes
négociations pour que les inuits
obtiennent du pouvoir fédéral qu'il
accepte de redécouper les frontières
intérieures du canada ça fait longtemps
qu'ils se sont battus pour ça et voilà
qu'enfin à la proche du nouveau
millénaire c'est arrivé cette liberté
retrouvée ne signifie pas pour autant
que les inuits renonce aux millions de
dollars de subventions que l'état
canadien continuera chaque année à
déverser dans l'économie locale
une plus grande autonomie ce n'est pas
l'indépendance loin de là d'ailleurs
personne ici ne la réclament et pour la
première fois depuis que des blancs
venus du sud ont foulé les glaces du
grand nord c'est d'égal à égal que les
inuits traiterons avec ottawa
la très lointaine capitale
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
inuits printemps inuits naissance du
nunavut
c'est de michel therrien c'est aux
éditions indigène du sport du tennis et
c'est à partir de demain animer un
direct sur france 2 et france 3 vendredi
samedi et dimanche 1er tour de coupe
davis pour l'équipe de france qui
affronte les pays-bas c'est aussi la
première fois que l'équipe de france
joue avec comme capitaine guy forget il
s'agit pour lui de faire au moins aussi
bien que son prédécesseur yannick noah
reportage christelle bertrand et
blessent grenier l'équipe de france est
en chantier
guy forget est le nouveau capitaine a la
lourde responsabilité de succéder à
yannick noah plus discret plus timide
que son prédécesseur
forget a d'abord observer les jours il a
aussi appris qu'un sélectionneur a
plusieurs fonctions pas toujours en
rapport avec le jeu
des petits problèmes d'intendance auquel
j'avais pas du tout été confrontés je
sais pas au niveau des voitures au
niveau de deuxième court d'entraînement
au niveau 2 et x des chambres d'hôtel et
du ménage
l'ambiance est studieuse seul le bruit
des balles résonne dans les arènes la
méthode forget elle s'inspire de la
méthode noir à quelques détails près on
fait pas peut-être de la sophrologie ou
la méditation comme on pouvait le faire
et claniques
mais bon je pense qu'il amènera aussi sa
touche personnelle qui nous permettra de
d'avoir une ambiance optimum au sommet
que cédric pioline et le pilier de
l'équipe
le numéro un français s'est entraîné
quinze jours sur terre battue pour bien
préparer la rencontre et même si fabrice
santoro s'est blessé forget n'a pas
perdu le moral
il sait qu'il peut compter sur jérôme
golmard pour jouer deux sens et le
double avec y aura obs
il ne resterait plus qu'à attendre le
coup du sort ce matin les équipes se
sont réunies pour connaître l'ordre des
matches avec richard krajicek récent
vainqueur du tournoi de key biscayne
les hollandais sont plutôt confiants des
français ont les statistiques pour eux
ils n'ont jamais perdu en coupe davis
contre les pays bas
demain jérôme golmard ouvre les
festivités face à crouch est dans les
arènes les français savent bien que pour
battre les hollandais il va falloir
prendre le taureau par les cornes
samedi au zénith à paris vas-y vas-y au
zénith c'est la confirmation d'une
chanteuse qui compose écrit et
interprète pour elle mais aussi pour
johnny hallyday florent pagny et pascal
obispo la confirmation d'un simple
talent reportage laurence piquet daniel
né
vous
faire le pitre c'est un peu sa façon de
se faire aimer et d'échapper au trac
depuis quatre mois zazie cours de ville
en ville le public la suit et
l'applaudît ll reste lucide
des moments où on vraiment je me fera
formidable et vous je mets deux ou trois
ou quatre jours a arrêté notre les
formules tout le temps et puis
heureusement j'ai des gens qui sont en
dehors de ce métier qui m'aide aussi à
gérer la vie parallèle qui du coup me
donne une vraie richesse le dire j'ai
vraiment besoin dont pour pour apprécier
la libye
pas de soi
tout le monde il est beau une chanson
contre le racisme nazi aime parfois
jouer les poils à gratter
c'est peut-être justement à nous de la
variété avec sa grande appellation
contrôlée de mettre un petit peu de
frais dans les cornichons est un peu
devenue telle la dans les eaux rendant
dans la choucroute prince et moi j'ai
pas la prétention de faire changer les
gens mais pour moi si ça peut déboucher
sur après une réflexion avec les amis
qui sont en train d'écouter l'album
c'est déjà ça zazie une grande fille
nature qui peut faire le clown crier et
même nous faire pleurer par exemple
quand elle écrit l'histoire d'une dame
amoureuse d'un homme volage aimant les
femmes tefal
on quittait
d
j'ai toujours tout
c'est pour ce faire
dumais
que
on me dit souvent que c'est plus facile
de parler de ses malheurs ou de ses
secrets à un inconnu
moi j'en suis convaincu c'est à dire que
j'ai peut-être 1-1 difficulté à dire ou
à communiquer
mon intimité à des gens qui sont très
proches de moi donc du coup je passe par
un énorme billets qui est le prisme de
de milliers de personnes
un regard qui ne trompent pas a dit m
les gens comme toutes les femmes elle
rêve d'un grand amour et d'être maman
une fille toute simple point
vas-y aux anict samedi nous arrivons à
la fin de ce journal auparavant je
voudrais vous rappeler quelques unes des
informations concernant le conflit
engagé par le temps au kosovo tout
d'abord la capture de trois soldats
américains que la division serbe
complaisamment montrer toute cette
journée captures réalisées par les dozos
monsieur milosevic monsieur clinton
menace monsieur milosevic si la plante à
l'intérêt de ces soldats monsieur
miscevic qui continue son opération
médiatique avec un leader serbe un
leader kosovar modéré monsieur rue
gauvin et puis les réfugiés continuent
d'affluer aux frontières de la macédoine
du monténégro et de l'albanie et enfin
plusieurs manifestations dont une cette
après midi à paris manifestation
d'opposants aux frappes de l'otan au
kosovo avec notamment la participation
du parti communiste ce qui souligne une
tension au sein du gouvernement se
trouve actuellement les ministres
communistes dans quelques instants la
météo de sophie davant suivi du point
route de valérie maurice à 29,55 donc
envoyé spécial avec une large partie
consacrée au kosovo à 23h10 eaux
profondes un film de michel deville avec
isabelle huppert et jean louis
trintignant
à une heure du matin le dernier journal
sera présenté par florence duprat à 1h20
la 25e heure et puis demain vous
retrouverez rachid arhab et à 20h
béatrice schönberg à lundi bonsoir merci